The monster falls.
Olive.
"We finally slayed the monster."
Water spirit.
"You did very well."
Wind spirit.
"We must return to the spirit realm."
Fire spirit. "This is goodbye."
Olive stands frozen.
Now, how do we get Olive home
from here?
Since her boat sank,
will she take a plane?
Something a little more imaginative.
She could fly home if she were a bird.
-What about flying with a parasol?
-You cannot fly with a parasol.
But you can!
The wind spirit appears before her
one last time and says,
"Olive, open your parasol."
Could you try opening the parasol for me?
"That parasol is your wings.
You'll be carried away
if you fly too high.
So, step on the ocean's waves,
the river's rocks,
and the fallen leaves on the lake."
That's a wonderful idea.
Right? After returning home,
Olive reunites with her father.
And the first thing she says when they're
reunited after crossing the ocean is...
What should it be?
"I'm home."
No, "Father?"
Do you have writer's block again?
Could you walk towards me from over there?
I'd like to visualize it.
I can do that.
Across the fallen leaves on the lake
if you can.
Understood.
No, that last bit was just...
I'm so jealous.
I want to try crossing this lake, too.
Do you think I could walk on those leaves?
One day...
I promise to show you one day.
Okay, Dad?
How I wish I could hear you call me that
a thousand times more.
I wish...
you didn't have to die.
If only you could have lived...
grown up...
How I wished that for you.
Did you see that?
I believe I made three whole steps.
Sir?
What is the matter?
Are you feeling ill?
After granting me this miracle,
I told her,
"I don't believe there is a God,
but if there were, it would be you."